last week the state of Indiana passed a
bill that allows businesses to deny
service to homosexuals in the name of
defending religious freedom it's a very
controversial law and I really wanted to
understand more about it because it's
all over the news and everyone's
discussing it so joining me now via
satellite and this cost us a lot of
money is Indiana's self-appointed
religious freedoms our don Biederman can
you hear me
[Applause]
[Music]
man he's popular alright I mean mr.
beederman thank you for joining me mr.
beederman I'm gonna come right out and
ask does Indiana's new law promote
discrimination against gays absolutely
not
in fact this law prevents discrimination
against good church-going folks who just
want their businesses homosexual free
okay now it is a known fact Konan if
there are any homosexuals nearby God
cannot hear your prayers okay okay but
you just you can't just identify every
homosexual at a glance well you can if
you've done the research and I have I
personally spent literally thousands of
hours studying the habits of homosexuals
by reading their literature and watching
their erotic adventures on DVD so sir
your research has consisted entirely of
reading and watching gay pornography
okay now you're starting to sound like
my ex-wife
I've also done extensive field work at
some of the hottest gay nightclubs
locally in the bra in fact I was just in
your city participating in LA's mr.
leather competition that won third prize
you want third prize Wow
[Applause]
now I can easily identify homosexuals in
all their various subcultures for
instance there's twinks punks
bears Cubs chubs pups otters feeders
muscle queens tops bottoms power bottoms
pitchers pitchers relief pitchers
pumpers priests freaks probers tickle
jail you know I think we got it we got
it yeah
lollipop boys flex BOTS nickel ponies
monkey liqueurs panties liquors Sizzlers
Sizzlers berry Queens Outback those are
just those those are just fast-food
chains just stop plus I found this great
app that helps me red flag homosexuals
it's called Grindr now you just swipe
left if they're straight and you swipe
right if they're handsome
okay now I'm not sure where the sir but
Grindr is a gay dating app mmm I suppose
it could be used that way if it fell
into the wrong hand
but honestly I don't even need this app
I have highly refined gaydar yeah and
I'm sure you do yes yeah if I sense
there's a homosexual nearby my gaydar
goes off and my penis instantly
lengthens and hardness defensively no no
that's not gaydar
I think we've heard enough I don't want
to hear any more I'm good but what's my
gaydar has gone off I can use my turgid
penis to poke the offending homosexual
off the premises get away gays
[Applause]
stop stop nope hey looks like there's a
bike messengering cutoff jeans at the
gym my gaydar is going
thank you so much you're good man
you